The opioid crisis in America is quite severe.
In 2018, 10.3 million people, ages 12 and
older misused opioids.
Most of these people misuse prescription painkillers,
often turning to the cheaper, more addictive
alternative, heroin.
There are 2 types of opioids: endogenous and
exogenous.
Endogenous opioids are neurotransmitters created
and regulated by the body.
Exogenous opioids are drugs: derived from
plants and produced synthetically.
These drugs are the source of the modern opioid
crisis.
Both endogenous and exogenous opioids interact
with opioid receptors.
These receptors are coupled with G-proteins
which help modulate neuron signaling.
One way that the use of opioids can affect
neuron pathways is by preventing neurotransmitter
release.
Here’s how it works:
In the presynaptic neuron, when the opioid
drugs bind to an opioid receptor, the G protein
complex splits into two subunits: G-alpha
and G- beta gamma.
The G-beta gamma subunit binds to the voltage
gated calcium channel, making them unable
to open, and blocking calcium ions from entering.
Neurotransmitter release to the next neuron
is unable to occur because it depends on the
presence of calcium ions in the presynaptic
neuron
Exogenous opioids can be extremely dangerous
because unlike endogenous opioids, they are
not moderated and bind to all available receptor
sites blocking crucial pathways between the
brain and respiratory system.
Every day, an average of 130 Americans die
from opioid overdoses.
Naloxone is a chemical compound that can be
used to block the effects of opioids, saving
lives in overdose situations.
It has a similar structure to the opioids
and binds to the same receptor site without
activating the G protein.
This prevents opioids from binding and keeps
the neuron pathway between the brain and respiratory
system open, ensuring that people can still
breathe.
The misuse of opioids can ruin lives.
Some solutions to help fight this crisis are:
To be well educated in the effects, to not
misuse prescription opioids, and to seek professional
help.